nos christophe prudhomme porte parole de
l'association médecins urgentistes de
france
bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation sur arte france face au co
vite 19 vous avez le sentiment que les
habitants de seine saint denis sont des
malades de seconde zone tout à fait la
seine saint denis depuis des années
dénonce le fait que les services publics
sont moins bien dotées en seine saint
denis et parmi les services publics
essentiels mais vous avez les services
les services publics de santé
il faut savoir que dans le département
nous disposons en période normale que
200 lits de réanimation pour une
population officielle de plus d'un
million six cent mille habitants une
population réelle qui frôle les un
million huit cent mille habitants sans
lui de l'animation c'est beaucoup trop
peu rien n'a été fait pour améliorer
l'état de nos hôpitaux y compris ces
derniers mois alors que le leur est aux
mains de lannion très fermement auprès
du gouvernement
et comme en plus nous avons une
population pauvre qui en plus
travaillent donc se déplace et plus
fortement exposée que la population qui
a la possibilité de faire du télétravail
de rester chez elle eh bien nous sommes
atteintes par une surmortalité
importante alors que au regard de notre
population à qui est plus jeune que la
moyenne
mieux de venir on être moi il ya moins
touchés en seine-saint-denis en tant que
médecin urgentiste de quelle façon est
ce que vous notez une fragilité plus
grande de la de la santé n'est plus
précaires vous savez nous manquons de
mettre sa généralistes ans puisque rien
n'est fait pour répartir de manière
homogène les médecins sur le territoire
donc une bonne partie de la population
n'a même pas de médecin traitant leurs
médecins traitants ce sont les urgences
et ils viennent aux urgences quand ils
sont dans un état santé déjà dégradée
mais avec une population jeune qui est
en mauvais état de santé de base qui se
nourrit mal qu'à une mauvaise hygiène
bucco-dentaire vous savez que coton des
pauvres on se nourrit moins bien on va
moi voir le médecin et donc forcément ça
a des conséquences en terme de deux
conditions de vie de santé et donc de
mortalité une filet est-ce que c'est lié
aussi à une façon de vivre par par
exemple plus multi générationnel où les
plus jeunes qui sont amenés à faire des
travaux plus proche du public sont en
relation le soir quand il rentre à la
maison avec des générations plus âgées
et trouve ça rentre en compte
oui vous savez qu'il ne le principal
lieu de contamination
c'est sur le jugement or quand
or nous avons énormément de logement
surpeuplé avec effectivement la
cohabitation de plusieurs générations et
ça favorise effectivement la
transmission du virus
on le sait depuis maintenant fort
longtemps et il s'avère que peu
d'efforts ont été faits justement pour
aller dans les quartiers pour informer
la population ça ils se sont pas les
grandes annonces national ces fameux bar
bob de dépistage
il faut que l'on ait des professionnels
qui aille là où vivent les gens certes
dans leurs appartements pour les
conseillers quand une personne est
infectée pour savoir si effectivement il
faut pas isoler cette personne dans un
autre lieu qui peut être un hôtel voilà
c'est du travail de terrain dont nous
avons besoin et ce travail de terrain
que pour ce travail de terrain en
déplaise à le cher président ce n'est
pas qu'une question d'organisation c'est
aussi une question de moyens pour aller
faire des visites à domicile il faut lui
personnel
et qui marche sur ses deux jambes c'est
pas qu'une question d'organisation et on
manque énormément de personnel en
seine-saint-denis et ce qui est encore
temps de changer la donne avec en
perspective une éventuelle troisième
vague
vous savez il faut pas parler de
première deuxième troisième vague il
faut comprendre que même si nous avons
le vaccin aujourd'hui ce virus va
continuer à être là cet hiver
sûrement cet été et l'hiver prochain
salut regard de l'évolution de ces
épidémies à concots n'est depuis le
depuis fort longtemps
le virus va pouvoir circuler pendant
trois quatre ans potentiellement donc il
va falloir apprendre à vivre avec et
apprendre à vivre avec ça veut dire se
donner les moyens de limiter les
contaminations
quand on a effectivement identifié les
lieux les lieux de transmission sont
claires ce sont c'est pas dans la rue
c'est pas dans la rue le port du masque
dans la rue ça mais bon ça fait joli à
la télé mais c'est pas ça qui est
efficace c'est effectivement comment on
limite les contaminations à la maison en
milieu professionnel
parce que c'est là qu'aujourd'hui sont
localisées les contaminations
donc ça nécessite joly c'est important
quand on a une population qui vit dans
des logements surpeuplés qui a des
conditions de travail qui nécessite de
multiples contacts
il faudra mettre beaucoup plus de moyens
en seine-saint-denis qu'ailleurs et
c'est pas là où on met plus de moyens
saleh pour rétablir l'égalité qui est un
droit constitutionnel et biens
appartiennent moment donné faut des
mesures inégalitaires et comme avec
monsieur verrou monsieur macro et ce
gouvernement le comprenne
parce que d'être mal traité comme on
l'est en seine saint denis
sacré de la colère je peux vous le dire
dans la population et chez les
personnels soignants aussi merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions christophe
prudhomme délégué cgt santé porte parole
de l'association médecins urgentistes de
francs